- I'm also a very talented rapper and
(audience cheering)
- I do freestyle rap.
- That's made up the spot.
- Yes.
It's improvised.
It's not written. It's not prepared.
It's not rehearsed.
One person is very excited for that.
(audience chuckling)
- Everyone else is like, can we leave now?
- [Audience Member] I love you.
- You love me, that's
very kind. Thank you.
I want to know what you
guys wanna hear a rap about
- [Audience Member] Depression.
- Did you say depression?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- As in, as in the, the mental,
the mental health problem
not the period in the 1930s.
And so when it comes to depression, let's
let's dive into that.
Do you said, do you
suffer from depression?
- [Audience Member] 100%
- 100%, wait, all the time?
- [Audience Member] All the time.
- All the time.
You're masking it very well.
I want another word.
(audience calling out)
- [Audience Member] Queen Elizabeth.
- Did you say queen Elizabeth?
(audience laughing)
- Well, that's very, that's pointed.
However, what we're
gonna do is combine that.
So we have queen Elizabeth's depression.
You shouted out Megan Markle.
Yeah, Okay.
(audience laughing)
I'm very much team Megan, whatever.
Yeah, Megan Markle.
- [Audience Member] Bidet.
- Or if you called her
by her Roman initials
thousand thousand.
(audience laughing)
So okay, Queen Elizabeth's depression.
Did you say bidet?
'Cause Will spoke about a bidet.
I like that. Okay.
So, okay.
Let's, so we got the
Queen's depression, bidets.
(audience yelling out)
- Whoa, whoa. Okay, okay.
Guys.
This is so raucous and unruly
and it makes me uncomfortable.
(audience laughing)
We're coming to this side.
- [Audience Member] The carnival.
- [Audience Member ] The gays.
- What, what's that? I'm sorry.
You said, the carnival,
and you said, the gays.
You said, the gays.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Erectile dysfunction.
- Okay, erectile dysfunction
- [Audience Member] Eh yo.
- The gays, the Queen's depression, bidet.
And then what are you shouting over here.
- [Audience Member] Putin's bedroom.
- Putin's bedroom?
(Audience Cheering)
Has there been a new
story story about this
recently that I didn't hear about?
- [Audience Member] It's up to you.
- It's up to me, cool.
- [Audience Member] Let go white boy.
- 'Cause I remember
there was all that talk
of like Trump getting
peed on during sex, right.
(audience laughing)
- I mean you guys know that, like, Biden,
pees on his wife during sex,
but that's just his incontinence
It's really common.
(audience laughing)
He doesn't mean to.
So the Queens depression, bidets,
the gays.
Oh that's gonna be good isn't it.
Erectile dysfunction and Putin's bedroom.
This then is a freestyle
That's rap matter from the
smart crowd based suggestions.
It's not written, it's not prepared.
It's not rehearsed.
And if you can drop that beat, dear sir,
it will not be as bad as
you're expecting it to be.
So let's play.
(audience cheering)
and have some fun.
Mm ah. Such a good beat.
That's great.
Let's have fun.
I love the little hand
signals you were doing.
Cool.
♪ Kinda acting with the hands ♪
♪ Like a signing to Italian song ♪
♪ The hands movin' two guys Italian ♪
♪ We're having fun ♪
♪ Their parade hand movements ♪
♪ Kinda looks like a limp wrist. ♪
♪ When I see the gays ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ Oh, higher in the air. ♪
♪ Well, you've got a flex
kinda flick with the elbow. ♪
♪ It'd be fun yeah. ♪
♪ I'm partial to hanging
out with the gays ♪
♪ In the carnival. ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ Even if I want to flow on the ocean ♪
♪ Yeah, once I went out
to the Stonehall bar ♪
♪ I walked in looking to
find myself a new papa ♪
♪ I found a daddy, a buddy ♪
♪ He was buying me the drinks ♪
♪ I referenced the gays ♪
♪ He said, what do you think? ♪
♪ I'm like, why are you really offended ♪
♪ Please don't kinda insert in it ♪
♪ The T-H-E, I don't respect you all ♪
♪ You could say gays ♪
♪ You could say homosexual ♪
♪ But if you got the
definite article in front ♪
♪ It's kind weird ♪
♪ Maybe move it away ♪
♪ And maybe shout out ♪
♪ I like this. ♪
♪ The word just grabs ya ♪
♪ Erectile dysfunction ♪
♪ You need the Viagra ♪
(audience cheers)
♪ Take a little pill ♪
♪ If you Joe Biden and over the hill ♪
♪ You needs to get a prescription. ♪
♪ To get a raised swole ♪
♪ Looking like a big American flagpole ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ The support of the 23% of men ♪
♪ Or maybe it's higher ♪
♪ Maybe then again yeah ♪
♪ You know them ♪
♪ The adverts done by Roman ♪
♪ They send it through your mailbox ♪
♪ If you were chosen
to get that treatment ♪
♪ No prescription ♪
♪ I wanted get a clean asshole ♪
♪ So the position that I drop ♪
♪ Is a nice little swap ♪
♪ I've got a bidet going cold and hot ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ If you adjust the temperature ♪
♪ Its much better than
any of your bidets ♪
♪ I can use the pressure. ♪
♪ I like to put it up ♪
♪ Like 10 outta 10, it feels amazing ♪
♪ Like getting rimmed by a man ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ There we go, gays, bidets so ♪
♪ And I told you so ♪
♪ I was in Buckingham Palace ♪
♪ I got one question ♪
♪ Like 'sup, Queen Lizzy ♪
♪ You sufferin' from depression ♪
(audience cheering)
Queen o'mine
♪ One is ever so upset ♪
♪ It's so easy pry ♪
♪ I'm like, oh, Lizzy ♪
♪ What's gotten into ya ♪
♪ She says, they want my
jewels back to India ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ I sold them all ♪
♪ The Colonials ♪
♪ They were like we want
reparations for Colonial ♪
♪ Like I said before ♪
♪ On a bookshelf ♪
♪ She'd be so sad ♪
♪ That she kills herself ♪
♪ I'm like, whoa Lizzy, please wait ♪
♪ How old are ya ♪
♪ 96, 97, maybe 98 in a month. ♪
♪ It will prove to be
a great celebration. ♪
♪ It's a jubilee ♪
♪ I love that you be clapping ♪
♪ I'm rapping about platinum ♪
♪ It's the platinum jubilee ♪
♪ It's what's gonna be happenin' ♪
♪ And I say ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ Me and my best dudes ♪
♪ Were off there to Red Square ♪
♪ To rescue any prostitutes ♪
♪ That he's taken there at gunpoint ♪
♪ I know Putin's done this ♪
♪ At some point he was always excited ♪
♪ And filled with glee ♪
♪ He wanted to get his
rocks off in the KGB ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ He says, I select you ♪
♪ Come on, lady to my bedroom ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ He's having sex in Russia. ♪
♪ He's shooting off his load ♪
♪ Like Lenin's tomb ♪
♪ Like he sees Stalin, Putin assumes ♪
♪ That no one knows what's going on ♪
♪ Where his friends be ♪
♪ But that position in his bed, I envy ♪
♪ Is about to come ♪
♪ But then he gets ended ♪
♪ Say what ♪
♪ He's assassinated from
behind by Zelenskyy ♪
(audience cheering)